okay so some of you might find this
interesting i've gotten a handful of
emails from from people saying david i
was loving those interviews of trumpest
candidates that you were doing over the
last few months but you haven't done one
for a while what's going on well it's
because they keep canceling on us they
something is going on and i'll tell you
what i believe it is where the trump is
candidates they agree to be on the show
we schedule it it's an hour before the
show
and then they cancel and then they say
oh well
and i'll tell you what i think is going
on so as a reminder we did a bunch of
these republican candidate interviews of
republicans endorsed by donald trump we
interviewed john gibbs that one was wild
it got almost half a million views i
can't imagine it was particularly good
for the john gibbs campaign we did one
with darlene swaffer she's the one who
could not or refuse to give a straight
answer to the question who is the
president of the united states and we
did some others and none of them really
went that well for the candidates but
people asked for more and so we had more
scheduled i think four or five different
ones but something
has happened between the time when they
agree and the time when we are ready to
do the interview they say yes i'll do it
we get it on the schedule and invariably
a few minutes to an hour to a couple of
hours before the interview they cancel
sometimes it's a no-call no-show
sometimes it's oh something came up oh
we have a conflict all right well let's
reschedule yeah we'll get back to you
about rescheduling and then they never
do
and it's quite a list now now i'm not
going to name names because
it's in a it seems inappropriate to name
names and also of the list of five or so
some of them might really have had a
conflict and i don't want to like pick
and single out the wrong person
but obviously something is going on now
our colleague john who's been scheduling
these and dealing with the schedulers
thinks the explanation is very simple
oftentimes either the candidate
themselves or if they have a publicist
or a communications person they get
excited that someone wants to talk to
them and they go yeah i'll do it that
sounds good
they don't research the show
and then they go to the channel
and they see john gibbs making a fool
out of himself and half a million views
or darlene swaffer becoming memed on
twitter with a hundred thousand views on
a stupid little twitter clip that we put
together because she can't say who the
president of the united states is and
then they say i'm going to bail out here
so we're available to chat
i want to learn about their ideas i want
to learn about the whole thing
and i also think i should mention like i
kind of get it in a way
doing this show isn't going to help them
you know to to win imagine that you're
running in the third district in
michigan or whatever right
to win you need to convince
not just all voters in that third
district of michigan because a lot of
them are not going to consider voting
for a lunatic trumpist you need to
convince the low information voters in
the third district of michigan
and they're mostly not in my audience
right i mean this is a show with a
mostly progressive audience yes some
center right and right wingers but most
of them don't live in the third district
of michigan or whatever the case may be
so i get it like at best doing an
interview on this show
it does nothing bad and gets you a
little bit of attention generally but
it's not the people that ultimately are
going to put you in office
and worst case it gets memed and it
hurts you so i can't say i blame them
but i wanted to put everybody on notice
with peace and love peace and love we're
doing what we can to get more of these
people on the show
most of them just decline and even the
ones that agree
i think we now have four in a row
who just bail
they just bail they end up not wanting
to do it